welcome back to facebook.com tonight
burberry's Valentine's Day advert is
accused of glamorizing mastectomies
should Brands be activists like this or
distinct to selling handbags we'll
debate that later but first she's been
nicknamed Christian mum Izzy Montague
launched the election in 2019 against
her son's London school over an LGBT
pride parade tomorrow her case goes to
court it's the first case of its kind in
the UK she will claim a pride parade
held at the school promoted gay
Lifestyles and indoctrinated children
and her child was four at the time it's
a debate raging on both sides of the
Atlantic in the U.S 78 of parents do not
believe sexual orientation or gender
identity should be taught to young
children and now Donald Trump has of
course got involved and said it's going
to be a central part of his bid to
return to the White House branding
gender ideology a cult
we're going to stop the left-wing
radical racists and perverts who are
trying to indoctrinate our youth and
we're going to get their Marxist hands
off of our children
we're going to defeat the cult of gender
ideology and reaffirm that God created
two genders called men and women
well a rock and feel bristling to my
side here don't join us by a polar and
agent he's also bristling we should tie
us out of that probably nodding away
also with me now is LGBT Rights Campaign
and the Fox News contributor Tommy
lehrero welcome a stellar panel I gotta
say for this all right uh Tommy later
let me start with you because it's been
a big burning issue in America now
raging away for quite some time it's one
of the reasons I think that Ron DeSantis
the governor of Florida has seen such
surging popularity potentially heading
him to the White House in this battle
over what you can teach at school with
young people in relation to this kind of
thing what is your view
listen we do not need to be teaching
this radical LGBT grooming agenda in
schools it's one thing if parents want
to do that on their own time that is a
parent's right to do that with some
exceptions of course but to bring this
in and bake this into a public school
curriculum is wrong and meanwhile
Chinese students are learning quantum
physics and we've got our students
learning how to twerk from drag queens
it's not going to end well this is
grooming this is ideological mind
control it's introducing this to a group
of individuals especially to young kids
who have no business learning any of
this sexually explicit material this is
not about being anti-gay or as the
incorrectly labeled Rhonda Sanders's
Bill don't say gay this is about keeping
this out of the classroom because it
does not belong there this is a grooming
agenda it is Extreme it is explicit it
does not belong in front of young
children at their school they should be
learning reading writing and arithmetic
not this filth well I think you've made
your position quite clear there Miss
Lauren I I imagine but it's actually
agree with every word of huh
well here in Britain we know from
research that nearly half of all lesbian
gay bisexual and transgender pupils in
our schools have been bullied
bullied teased some sometimes subjected
to physical violence
simply because of their sexuality or
their gender identity so this education
in British schools is designed to combat
bullying and to promote understanding
and acceptance none of the teaching of
British schools is sexually explicit nor
is any of the material in United States
schools is all about promoting
understanding and tolerance so what's
just been said is a complete
misrepresentation of the teaching and I
think that any parent would want their
child to be brought up in a school where
understanding acceptance of difference
is valued where people are not bullied
because of their sexuality okay
look I I don't disagree with some of
what you just said I think the issue
here is age I've I've got four kids
you've all gone through obviously all
this I just think the idea that at four
any child should be exposed to anything
like this is ridiculous I really do
they're just nowhere near old enough to
to understand or even begin to
understand any of the stuff that this is
being taught in this way so although
this woman in this court case did this
on religious grounds
um she's a Catholic and this is what her
you know she believes her religion has
taught it to believe that's one debate
but actually The Wider debate for me is
what age should we be teaching kids
about things like gender identity and
should they be compelled to go on Pride
parades and so on at the age of four I
don't think so
no one is compelling any child to go on
a pride parade anywhere not in school
not in the street nowhere and when it
comes to teaching the teaching is not
about sex at a young age it's about
relationships and the fact that some
kids will be in married heterosexual
families some will be in single families
some will be in extended families and
some will be in same-sex families it's
all about different families that kids
in our schools are part of and of course
all those kids should feel loved and
appreciated the essence of this teaching
is about love and respect for other
people it's not it's not about sex at
all okay let's bring in the panel here
Paula good evening I completely agree
with Peter and I'm really concerned that
a commentator could use the words
radical and grooming when we're having a
very sensible conversation about helping
children to understand who they are what
as we saw that Paula 78 of Americans
would share a lot of the views that
Tommy Lauren expressed it they do not
want to see kids age four getting
bombarded with this kind of ideology at
school but what kind of ideology what
exactly are we talking about and if you
listen to Peter
I'll give an example when you start
teaching kids I mean the BBC for example
had a one of their teaching videos so
there were over a hundred genders the
BBC should not be teaching children
there are a hundred genders one of them
was Astra gender which is an affinity
with the Stars right the ones flying
around the moon so I'm sorry I do
actually think the children should not
be exposed to that kind of classroom
be children particularly
who are desperately concerned about what
is being taught in primary school and
the truth is we don't know what's been
taught about the high percentage of
children who suffer bullying who are
vulnerable we're safe
empathy that's got nothing to do with
gender ideology we don't need to take a
pride parade that's what this is about
it's not about being proud to be gay
yeah
speak tolerance and understanding but
not at four five six seconds
aside from all of this we actually teach
sex quite explicitly in heterosexual
relationships from a really young age
you actually have children in Nativity
plays where you're playing a mother who
has an Immaculate Conception and then
gives birth to a baby what are you
teaching about you're talking about if
you've ever as I have done four times
had kids you've appeared in these things
they thought they haven't got a
Scooby-Doo or any of them
what's the purpose of that story the
purpose of that story is love yes the
purpose of that story is bringing people
together
well I want to bring in I want to bring
back Tommy Lauren here because we've had
a really scandalous case in the last few
days Tommy here in the UK of a
transgender person uh who committed two
rapes when identifying as a man rapes of
women and before the the court case
started it had transitioned to become a
woman and then was tried under a female
name and then when he's convicted this
person I'm using that term deliberately
I think because I I'm unconvinced by
this transition process when this person
was then convicted the
brought in a law which allowed this
trans person to then be put into a
woman's prison
as a woman who had literally got a penis
and raped two women so that not only
were they being punished by being put
into a place where they could attack
other women but they were being treated
as if they were legitimately exactly the
same as a woman born to a female
biological body what do you make of that
but peers you're wrong you're wrong yeah
this is a problem that we are
encountering okay
all right well hang on let's go to Peter
first tripped me on what I said that was
wrong she was put in
she was put into a woman's prison but in
a segregation unit where she had no
contact with other women but she
shouldn't have been put in there at all
a rapist must never
a raper should never have contact or be
a potential risk to Other Woman She's
now been moved to a male prison quite
rightly and again she will have no
contact with women
say she has been moved to a male prison
quite rightly though because that
immediately to me sounds incredibly
confusing you're saying she so you
presumably think that she is a woman and
yet she is being moved to a male prison
because nobody else actually now thinks
she is actually a woman she's a man with
a penis who raped two women I mean
that's the reality even her ex oh his or
her or purse whatever their ex-wife said
that this is all a complete scam to game
the system and get into a softer prison
well I think you're probably right I
think it does look like the person is
gaming the system but you know the fact
is that the transfer to a woman's prison
was not based on any new law introduced
by the Scottish government it was based
on existing policy which was to respect
a person's gender identity but not under
any circumstances put someone who'd
committed crimes against women in
contact with other woman and that's why
she was in a segregation unit yeah look
I I don't think I what I said was wrong
because by new law I mean by new law I
meant this is a law that's come in in
recent years which allowed that gender
identity to be enforced in the way that
it was enforced and I Tommy Lauren I
just have a massive problem with people
this is what I've been saying from the
start about this trans debate the moment
the moment you open the door to this
kind of abuse by people it will happen
you know it's a bit like cheating in
sport once you allow it everyone starts
to cheat right you're going to get a
load of people who you know male rape
it's male sex offenders what's Utopia
for them if they get convicted being
taken from a Men's prison with their
pariahs and put into a woman's prison
surrounded by people they can attack
but they're over 200 yeah so I want to
be very clear about this not everybody
who is transgender does something like
this my turn to talk not everybody who
is transgender is going to do something
like this but you're opening the door
for this and even beyond that when we're
not even talking about a women's or a
Men's prison let's just talk about here
in the USA and I know in the UK as well
when they're having biological men
compete in women's sports using the same
locker rooms exposing themselves to the
female athletes that are often in high
school it's inappropriate it doesn't
belong in schools it doesn't belong in
society this free-for-all you can
identify as anything you can abuse the
system you can abuse this whole notion
of gender identity it's gone too far and
to even criticize it now has been
labeled bigotry it's not it's reality
okay to protect people we need to
especially protect young people well I I
actually agree with all that uh Peter
tactical I mean I've been watching some
interviews you've been doing I do think
you've been you know on a mission of
Discovery yourself about the perils here
of this particularly in this case in
Scotland of this rapist but if I was to
ask you now a question which has become
the most dangerous controversial
question in the world for some reason
you know what he's a woman to you
a trans woman is a woman but not the
same as biological women there's a
difference between biological sex and
gender identity both are equally valid
both equally deserve respect and equal
rights there should not be a competition
between biological women and trans women
they both suffer from very elevated
levels of domestic violence sexual
assault including rape that applies to
both trans women and other women as well
so let's find the common ground rather
than fighting each other the enemy is
misogyny that's the enemy not trans
woman well I think the enemy is misogyny
in many ways but I think the enemy is
also virtue signaling because the idea
that you can let trans women who have
massively Superior physical bodies
compete in professional sport against
women born to female inferior physical
bodies I think is for the birds but we
we will actually that's an unfortunate
Turner phrase I have no offense to
anyone who's offended by my use of the
word Birds
um but thank you very much Peter tatchel
great to have you on the program thank
you Tommy lateren great to see you